Aquí en Chile,
pero yo quiero que alguien me explique qué son
las alianzas amarillas,
rojas, verdes,
o sea yo quiero saber qué significado tienen,
porque a mí
todos los años me escriben personas pidiéndome saludos
para jardines,
colegios, escuelas especiales.
Bueno, aquí una chica me pone,
te cuento
en el jardín están en la semana de aniversario,
entonces están haciendo como competencias y a mi hija
que ella va en medio mayor,
es la alianza amarilla
y para ganar puntos
están pidiendo saludos de presentadores,
influencer, etc.
acá otra chica me dice lo mismo
y me dice un saludo a la escuela especial
del lenguaje municipal de Arauco
que está en el mes de aniversario cumpliendo 15 años,
en especial la alianza roja
y por acá otra chica me pregunta, me pone, hola Elías,
con gusto saludarte,
espero que estés bien.
Quería pedirte un favor,
estoy en una competencia de aniversario
en el jardín de mi hija
y nos están pidiendo un saludo
de personas famosas
y quería saber si me podías ayudar con un video
enviando un saludo a la alianza amarilla del jardín
Esdras de Maipú.
Yo quiero que alguien me explique
qué significado tiene la alianza
y qué diferencia tiene cada color.
O sea, a mí me gusta apoyar
pero nadie me ha explicado de qué se trata
y me gustaría saber como que diferenciarlo, pues la roja,
la amarilla, el año pasado fue la verde.
Yo tengo años aquí en Chile
y he colaborado todos Los años,
pero como que nadie me explica de qué se trata,
me gustaría saber,
pues obviamente porque
quiero seguir apoyando,
pero no quiero pasar como que por ignorante,
porque desconozco el tema o porque simplemente
siempre envío el saludo pero nunca me explican
bien de qué se trata.
Bueno, ¿mis hijos eh?
Igual bendiciones
a todas esas personas que están haciendo esas alianzas
de diferentes colores.
Sé que es un trabajo grandioso
que están haciendo con estos niños,
pero por favor,
si alguien sabe del tema y me puede enseñar, gracias